tu adores cette cuisine la cuisine c'est
le combat du jeune femme claire moi à
oui je les adore
j'ai connu avec ses imperfections
et je l'aimé comme ça mais ça me fait
mal dans un sens du devoir
on peut pas c'est pas comme la vraie vie
mais le matériel se dégrade et une
caille matériel s'est dégradée pas beau
alors que nous y resterons conserver
loin des plateaux télé c'est depuis chez
elle face caméra que lisa laflamme
journaliste vedette d'une chaîne de télé
anglophone annoncé son licenciement
le 29 juin j'ai été informé que bell
média avait choisi de mettre fin à mon
contrat bourges site il des raisons
stratégiques mettant une fin brutale à
ma longue carrière à la télé selon des
témoignages lisa laflamme auraient été
évincés d'antenne à cause de ses cheveux
gris qu'elle assume depuis la crise du
coc vide après avoir dû comme beaucoup
de femmes renoncer aux coiffeurs et aux
teintures régulière pour le directeur de
la chaîne rien à voir avec ses cheveux
ni son âge mais trop tard le mal est
fait
anita qui tenait vraiment à nous montrer
qu'elle n'avait aucun mais alors aucun
problème moteur dans le bas du dos
sic afin de pousser sa saf fr
oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ses consoeurs au canada elle appelle
tous les journalistes à porter une
perruque grise en soutien alors voila
moi j'ai décidé d'eux m'exécuter sur ce
plateau et de m
le père est gris jusqu'à la fin de ce
bloc notes n'ont
fait raison vous dormez sur quoi
exactement c'est de la peau de bête à
ces moelleux qu'est-ce que ça c'était
vicky que ce moelleux ou et c'est un
mois le moderne ça je triche un peu
je suis dur à la surface mais doux dans
mon lit ah oui
mais je sais aussi être dur relie
ce couple là tellement fusionnel
tellement amoureux tellement merveilleux
et j'aimerais et oui eh ben je les envie
c'est un couple merveilleux très
amoureux et je souhaite chers janvier
amoureux ça vous calmera
[Applaudissements]
je vais être très clair avec vous
bernard n'y a rien de personnel quant à
ma vie amoureuse elle va très bien merci
je suis ça fait 23 ans que avec le même
mais tout va bien je suis content ça se
voit pas il ya juste un an je partirais
ton truc
[Rires]
comment tu venais pas de travail et pas
franchement hâte bien j'étais
content quand un grand merci aux légumes
car moi j'ai pas ouais charte a chassé
cette cuisine permet aux badauds des
franchement ouais je fais des bisous
plus tard
hier par exemple j'ai péché pendant 13
heures pendant 13 heures mais moi je
m'ennuierais comment 13h au bout d'une
canne comme ça mais j'ai pas vous avez
vous dit pas je deviendrai dingue non
c'est mieux que le sexe
c'est mieux que le sexe yes we max
beaucoup mieux
mais eux
[Rires]
au
ptz
[Rires]
plus compétitifs comme tartuffe
images
ça veut dire que vous êtes un très bon
pêcheur ou très mauvais en sexe
c'est avec je crois que je suis plutôt
bon sexe ah oui donc c'est vraiment
énorme alors
moi je sui team booba mais ce qui me
dégoûte c'est d'être dans votre équipe
qu'est ce que vous venez [ __ ] ici
répondre à ces comptines et répondre à
cette manette
mais la réponse qu'est ce que je viens
faire là c'est beau jeu les invités
effectivement j'ai besoin d'une
expertise que vous n'êtes pas qu'il faut
que tu te donnes et voilà
vaty prend les téléphones portables
analysant si
on voit là et pendant les coupures ont
les rangs allez hop téléphone portable
et quand même ça exactement d'asie donne
analyse le bien voilà même japon au
travail et
vous êtes gentils nous est liée à la
réalisation qui nous envoient des
messages sur nos portables et vous avez
me vient c'est la base qui m'écrit pour
savoir aussi gueule ou on en est
quand c'était la mode des antilles
vacances vous étiez là éructer
maintenant booba est à la mode et le
soutien plutôt vous êtes à éructer dans
une semaine casquette à l'envers ou
chanter durable et vision
[Applaudissements]